what is this Kobe process you'll pick up
the phone you'll call people who are
leaders in industry and you just pick
their brain exactly this is that a
minute you know not just cold call
people absolutely as a cold call people
and just pick their brain about stuff
and you know I'm some of the questions
that I ask will seem really really
simple and stupid quite honestly for
them but if I don't know I don't know I
have to ask and so I'll just do that
I'll just ask questions that I want to
learn more about how they build their
business how they run their companies
and how do they see the world and and
you went to Apple today you spend some
time there yeah went up to Apple spent
the day there talking with Johnny and
just kind of picking his brain about
prodding things like that and it makes
them who they are why very very curious
about that understanding that and I
think once you have passionate thing
that you're passionate about now you can
look at other people or other entities
or other things or works of art you can
draw things from that to help you be
better I would choose by looking for
those common denominators Johnny wanted
to know how do I prepare her how do I
prepare how do I study how do I view the
game how do you build your game and my
response is much like the way he builds
products and you think sequentially oh
yeah you look at this the end result of
what you want to create but know what to
create that there's so many other little
things that go into this massive entity
that device it's no different than
building my basketball game you start
with what do you want your game to be
what would make your game most
unstoppable or hard to deal with and now
you work backwards from there
and you start building it one piece at a
time one move at a time one countered so
there's a lot of similarities there